John isn't really my father son his last
name isn't really snow John's real name
hey everybody so I've been getting a lot
of requests to do a video for the sons
of the Dragon which is Martin's new
material that he published for the sons
of Aegon the conquerer he had two sons
Inez and make or the cruel so it's
fascinating to learn how may Gore got
his name maegor the cruel because a lot
of the things that happened during that
period coincide with things that are
happening on the TV show right now so
I'll point out some of the similarities
like there's Cersei the cruel but you
also have people like Jon Snow and
Daenerys so there is a new round of the
giveaway it's for the new book all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video we're
doing weekly videos until season 8 gets
here so we got a long ways to go but
coinciding with all this we also have
the development of the five separate
prequels so this is where we get into
Targaryen prequel territory because of
the five prequels that they're
developing right now three Martin is
working on I believe that a lot of them
have to do with the Targaryen family
during different periods in history
because even though they're all supposed
to be very different and take place in
very different time periods that were
all centered around big events in the
history of the world in most of those
big events tie back into the Targaryen
family in one way or another even if
it's back in ancient Valyria which I do
believe is one of the prequels any
Valyrian prequel would obviously tie in
with a lot of the Targaryen family even
though they themselves were a relatively
minor house in the freehold but there is
also another book that's probably going
to be released next year that is not
winds of winter so while the sons of the
Dragon is just about Aegon two sons the
book that Martin is probably going to
publish next year or early 2019 is going
to be called fire and blood and that's
the complete history of the Targaryen
family starting with Aegon the conquerer
so with exception to the time period
that takes place during the upbringing
of Aegon v because he's dunk from duncan
egg and they confirmed they're not doing
tales of duck and egg for one of the
prequels anything else that he's been
riding his fair game so he essentially
has a blueprint for all the Targaryen
Kings going back to a colonic
there are a number of big events that we
can talk about in separate videos when
they give us some more prequel
information the head of HBO said that
he's received completed scripts for some
of these and he's really really excited
so there will probably be some more
prequel news in the next couple of
months in the next year so if you're a
big fan of Targaryen history there will
be a lot of it starting next year but
one of the most interesting things about
these stories in addition to being just
more Song of Ice and Fire content is
that they also provide historical
context for events that are unfolding in
present-day with the main characters on
the TV show so sons of the Dragon opens
with sort of a historical context for
how it was that Aegon conquered the
Seven Kingdoms it then because the
dominant religion in Westeros at the
time was the faith of the seven how he
was able to slide the sister-wives in
their incestuous relationship past the
High Septon because normally that would
be a big no-no so the tale of a gods two
sons becomes this parable for what it
means to be a strong leader in how you
deal with situations to keep things from
spiraling out of control in the kingdom
so both of his sons are born to his
different sisters his older sister gave
birth to a niece he was born very weak
people were worried about him he wasn't
this strong warrior figure but because
Aegon was still touring the kingdom in
his early life he got to tour around
with him his second son maegor who would
eventually become maegor the cruel was
more like the mountain but there's this
really interesting dichotomy you
actually see aspects of Rey guards
personality in both of these two
brothers so imagine Meg or having all of
the warrior qualities of Rhaegar that
all of the more sensitive more practical
things going to Annies without any of
the good leadership skills so the idea
is is that you have the heir apparent
inez who's very beloved by the people
but is terrible at making decisions
worried about pleasing people and then
you have maegor who seems like he's an
amazing warrior but just a terrible
terrible person so eventually what
happened is is that in his final years
Aegon the Conqueror started turning
King's Landing into the King's Landing
of today and it started out as this
military camp they called it King's
Landing because that's where he first
sat down when he conquered the Seven
Kingdoms went back to dragonstone then
left his only surviving wife visenya
the mother of maegor the cruel to
oversee the construction of the red key
or what would eventually become the red
keep while he was back at Dragonstone
maegor was still living there he was
about Joffrey's age he still wasn't
quite 13 or 14 he doesn't have a lot of
friends he's quick to anger he doesn't
forgive people and he just kills
anything that gets in his way like
there's a horse that kicks him he kills
the horse then chops off the stableboys
face when the stable boy comes running
to try and save the horse so you see the
early signs of a Joffrey in the making
but in the next couple of years
Aegon dies of a stroke no foul play is
suspected make or burns the body which
is the Valyrian custom you know like
burning bodies is actually a pretty
important thing to do in present day so
that they can't be turned into the dead
I think I've mentioned it in previous
Targaryen videos but a lot of the
Valyrian customs seemingly are built to
fight the night King and the White
Walkers even though the rise of the
lawyer in Freehold happened after the
first long night but then inez his crown
King everyone starts bowing down to him
but when his brother maegor Baus to him
he says no no we're going to rule the
kingdom together so now you start to see
some of the problems with weak
leadership so eventually an issue of
succession arises once
inez starts having children and his
wife's womb is like a royal bloom they
just shoot out child after child after
child so meg or gets kicked out of the
line of succession and his mother
Visenya who's Aegon surviving sister the
Dowager queen at the time gets really
upset by this like my son may Gore
should be next in line for the throne
so they concoct this idea to use
Targaryen custom when brother to sister
cousin do cousin to betroth maegor to
Annie's oldest sister but everybody just
says hard pass on that and the faith at
the time was hardcore against it like
they were really really upset about the
idea of Targaryens marrying Targaryens
and unlike his father Aegon Annies is
afraid of upsetting them so he Baus to
their will and they said no maegor
cannot marry one of my children so you
start to see this division between the
brothers whereby maegor really wants the
throne in Annies wants to make him happy
but he also wants to make the faith of
the seven happy so eventually Meg or at
the age of 13 marries someone called
circe Hightower don't you just love the
imagery that that name evokes in
present-day maegor who would become mega
with accrual married to someone named
Circe and now in present day you have
Queen Cersei the cruel but she had
trouble having children Meg or being an
awful person took a second wife against
the wishes of the faith of the seven but
Annie's had to banish him to Pentos for
the faith of the seven so he went
against his brother to please the faith
of the seven it at the time Inez had
given maegor the sword Blackfyre had
belonged to their father and his dragon
balerion the black dread so through weak
leadership the kingdom has started to
revolt maegor was the one to put down
that revolt
so now Inez had banished him to Pentos
so the kingdom hated the current king
Inez they sort of liked maegor but
maegor was a terrible person who would
just kill anybody who got in his way so
he was very good at putting down
rebellions remember how maegor is the
king that put down the firth faith
militant uprising the same way that
Cersei blew up the great Sept he built
the dragon pit at the site of the old
set that he blew up during that uprising
so that uprising itself started during
the reign of his brother Inez when he
tried to Wed one of his sons to one of
his daughters so the faith said that was
the last straw so they formed the first
faith militant the poor fellows the
warrior sons and they started going
crazy in King's Landing
Inez died under mysterious circumstances
while in the care of may Gore's mother
Queen Visenya so because there have been
such chaos the kingdom had hated Inez so
much the succession past to make or like
Visenya declared that meg or was the
next king he took the iron throne but by
that time
Inez had already had more sons they all
claimed rights to the throne bangor
eventually killed the two older ones
took the throne the faith militant
uprising was still a relatively big
problem then through his own tyranny he
just became this really awful person in
his remaining years and died under
mysterious circumstances so one of
Annie's surviving sons Joe Harris became
King and he became known as Joe Harris
the wise so you see some of the
parallels in present day like even some
of the names recur you have Cersei the
cruel you have the idea that some great
Targaryen will come to succeed her and
lead the realm into a new era Prospero
like Daenerys is trying to break the
wheel I know we all have ideas about
who's going to survive the final season
but you just get the idea that Martin
introduces really big concepts like
marrying people within your own family
you have Jon Snow Daenerys and
present-day the struggle that they have
like what do we do about this how does
the realm feel about that how would they
deal with people who speak out against
in a relationship and then sort of the
broader context for what happens to
people who aren't strong leaders or good
people finding ways to deal with really
bad situations or preventing them from
happening in the first place so I don't
know that the show is gonna deal with it
a lot but you have the idea that
Daenerys needs to be this amazing leader
and deal with a lot of the politicking
in the realm while they're dealing with
the actual battle with the knight King
but just a reminder about the season a
production schedule they're supposed to
wrap by the summer next year so even if
we don't get new episodes till 2019 they
haven't quite started to do it yet but
they'll probably release in production
teasers like hey here's this cool
behind-the-scenes here's some of the
costumes here's some of the sets here's
some of the crazy special effects that
we're working on so I'm expecting that
to start towards the end of the year
early next year believe all your
requests for Game of Thrones videos in
the comments below
congratulations - Owen squelch you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here to learn all
about the season 8 schedule and you can
click here to learn more about the
season 8 cast that they just announced
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight